[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Sabrina
is in San Antonio hi Sabrina welcome to
the Ramsey Show hi sir how are you
better than I deserve what's
up hi so me and my husband we are on
baby set 2 we're almost done we have
about 12,000 left on our car and my
husband keeps trying to convince me that
we should trade it in because we have I
guess
equity in it right now and so we have
12,000 left I Kelly BL booked our car
it's around
22,000 he is thinking we should upgrade
to um a bigger vehicle um so this value
of the new vehicle would be
25,000 so about 3,000 more um and so I
just wanted to see your opinion I
refused to go to the lot because I don't
you know want to make a bad decision so
um we have about six months left
projected um until we pay it off and he
just thinks we should trade it right now
and we're going to pay it off regardless
this year um so that's kind of his
mindset I just want to get your
opinion how old are you
guys uh we're 29 28 and we've done the
stupid um 10 years of car payments and
I'm so over it but he just thinks we
should upgrade to the biggest one which
is the Yukon right now we have a a GMC
at kadia so he's wanting the more why do
you need why do you need to
upgrade um his reasoning or you know the
big reason would just be more room uh we
have four kids and um so there's really
no trunk space um so it's I know it's
silly but you do know they have large
SUVs that are cheaper than 20 don't
you yes does
he uh yes he do so part of the problem
is we are not on baby step 2 you
are m he's
not yeah he's wanting to stay into debt
it sounds like he's trading in one car
payment for a slightly bigger car
payment yeah like his his like view is
because I told him you know um you know
the way Ramy does it is we cash flow and
then we trade it in and then we pay the
difference and he's like well why don't
we just do that now and then pay it off
um all that once but I'm like no I'm so
ready to be done and he's like it's just
3,000 more and I'm like well that's just
well the Dealer's not going to give you
22 for it if you trade it in no that's
true too but but let's just stay with
the concept for a second the concept
though is he's willing to be in he's
willing to continue to borrow
money to get what he
wants yeah when he wants
it yes you got a fifth kid in the family
you didn't even know
it
yes so I don't think the car is the
issue I think the car is is revealing
the issue that you all are not on the
same
page okay yeah yeah and if I'm you
that's what's
disturbing
M because here's what you would really
do if you wanted a bigger car you would
um buy an $188,000 one instead of a
$25,000 one and that would get you out
of debt faster and you'd have a bigger
car
correct correct yeah so I think we have
a discuss I think the two of you need to
have a discussion about the fact that
the way you feel about debt and the way
you feel when he acts this
irresponsibly and contrary to what you
believe and how you want to how you're
you thought we were I you know it sounds
like this honey I thought we were agreed
that we were getting out of debt and
staying out of debt and now you're
coming in here and extending the time
that we're in debt to buy something that
we obviously can't afford why didn't you
come in here and suggest we buy
something
18,000 that is
larger because there's $18,000 SUVs out
there
agreed agreed yeah yeah and why didn't
you bring that in and then we'd had
something to talk about cuz that gets us
out of debt faster and we get a larger
car but instead you're scaring the crap
out of me that I'm going to have to
struggle with you the rest of our lives
on this money issue this is really scary
for me and you ought to bring that up to
him that
way okay because you don't really you
you know you laughed but you don't
really want to be married to a little
boy you want to be married to a man
that's walking along beside
you yeah shared goals and it it's not
cute that you're the mommy it's not fun
for you that's why I ask how old you
guys are cuz I was a little bit thinking
you were a lot younger honestly like you
were 22 or something and he still hadn't
grown up you know but um but maybe he's
29 and but you know no I would not go
along with this I would not go to the
dealership I will not sign this I don't
believe in it you're scaring the crap
out of me but the car is not the problem
the problem is that you would bring this
in here knowing how that's going to make
me feel that you disrespect me on that
level if I'm you that's how I'm
feeling yeah it be like you know let's
let's pretend Sharon Rams came in and
suggested we borrowed money can you
imagine how that would
go you know I mean it's I'd get
pay-per-view tickets to see yeah that
would be a hillbilly knockdown oh my
gosh unbelievable that'd be a one of
those fights right but I mean obviously
we we've had those fights long ago in
our marriage we got past them but I I I
want you I'm really concerned that you
use this opportunity to get the two of
you on the same page more than I'm
concerned about the car
transaction mhm and maybe bringing up we
could buy one for 18 why didn't you
bring me that is a good way to start
talking about it but most of all if I
were you I would talk about how it makes
you
feel when he um you know how it makes
you scared that that he you know he's
going to mess up everything after you
guys have worked so hard to get it
cleaned
up you know it's just at least he didn't
come in and go I want to borrow $60,000
and buy a brand new something you know
he didn't say that so he he's still
thinking he's still think he's gonna get
paid off in in a year but but you know
that means he's kind of like a two you
know on a scale of 1 to 10 right he's
not he didn't go to he didn't take it
all way make the problem slightly worse
yeah yeah but but but the big problem is
is that that's a slippery slope I mean
once you stick your toe in that water
The Vortex will suck you in you know
it's just like it's hard to go on the
lot of a car dealer and not leave
without a car it is dangerous it is cuz
they're fabulous cars and they're even
if the Sal even if the salesman sucks
the cars are fabulous start looking at
these new features and you're like oh
man we got a lot more room these little
kids are on top of each other I'm having
to you know the one benefit though of
having them on top of each other is you
can discipline them all at once that's
easier just you can reach you can reach
them
all oh that might be a that's the
parenting style Dave used to do back in
his day I did I grew up in the day when
your mother would reach across the back
seat and you could not find a way you
could not get away
there was no escaping there was no
dodging it's hard to do in the
Yukon it was Within Reach I'm just
saying well some of them have automatics
that do that now automatic moms they
just is that a thing I'm kidding that's
a feature moms would pay for I would pay
for it as a as a grandparent but there
you go just zap you in the seat if
you're misbehaving just a little z z Zip
Zip There You Go oh so yeah the key here
is either sell the car private and uh
you'll she'd have 10K left after that
and they'd save up and pay for a car
with cash or wait pay it off then they
can sell it and upgrade with cash either
way or if you want to reduce the debt
okay she said she owes 12 it's worth 20
and if you sold it for 22 and you bought
something for 18 you would only owe
eight you know and you pay that off in
less than a year yep but that does
that's not really the strategy the the
reason for bringing that up is to point
out that he didn't bother to go that
direction it was going if he had gone
that direction I'd have actually maybe
gone with him you know what I'm saying
sure yeah you you want to move up in car
and down in debt yeah a plan up in size
but not in value yeah um actually move
down in value when down in debt but up
in size yeah I'm for that it's like
people call up and say you know we owe
$112,000 on our car and it's worth
$112,000 uh or $10,000 or whatever or
you know but it's a you know we have a
you know a tiny little Honda or
something and we've got like two kids on
the way what are we going going to do
well you can move to a
$122,000 van it's a break even scenario
but don't go further in debt people use
all these events to justify going
further in debt it's so easy to justify
going into debt especially cars well
Dave it's for the safety and reliability
no it's not it's for you it's for you
it's for you little boy little girl I
want my TWU that's how that's how they
sound TW I want my TW my
TWU I'm sure your sounds like that I
want my TW what that's Dave's grandkid
right there this is the ramsy show
create your free every dooll budget
today the simplest way to budget for
your life